well you just gave a commencement speech
at USC now that's a big deal I think we
have a picture over there there we go
you told a very funny story in that
commencement speech I believe it's a
true story it is a true story you're
talking about yeah yeah professor there
was it used to play a prank on a
professor yeah I would I was not a very
serious student
sir mean you cuz you strike me as like a
real guy no I know people think oh you
must have really been into school no I
wasn't I had a buddy of mine who said
just on a lark you should come and crash
our class for no good reason and so on
kind of a I would say every three weeks
I would I would knock on the class room
door dressed as a janitor and just show
up in the middle of Professor goddess
man's literature class and with a lit
cigarette and a cleaning bucket and a
mop and say things like no one threw up
in here
[Laughter]
they send me from physical plant they
told me a kid threw up I don't see any
vomit did the professor get mad well the
I left you know my friends are smirking
in the back of the class and thinking
okay that was fun but who knows what the
consequences will be a week later I get
grabbed on the shoulder it is the
professor who I'm thinking oh I'm about
to apologize he said keep doing that
that is the funniest thing seriously yes
so like I said once a month I would come
and show up as the janitor guy one time
I showed up with the power drill I've
stood outside of his door and I just
started operating the power drill he
said to the class I wonder if that's our
friend the janitor and I walked in as if
on cue and class kind of exploded and I
he would just play my straight man I
would I would spend five minutes fixing
a light socket that's a great that's
enough what a great professor he was he
was instrumental in you know kind of
allowing me to be me yeah yeah you know
what's great is that huh
well god bless ya professor Ronald
goddess Minh well you've clearly grown
up and you've matured we're gonna take a
break we'll have more with Will Ferrell
in just seconds to go
you